Final Fantasy 16 reviews are here it
currently has an 88 out of 100 on
Metacritic but it is very early so it is
still subject to change starting with
gamer Aunt hey who gave it a full 100
with an interesting opening remark they
said the game is by no means perfect its
pacing is inconsistent and side quests
can be hit or miss but the combination
of the combat and the story at large are
strong enough to reduce any complaints
to minor quibbles IGN gave it a 9 out of
10 saying featuring fast reflex driven
action-heavy combat Final Fantasy 16 is
certainly a departure from what fans may
expect out of a Final Fantasy game but
its excellent Story characters and World
building are right up there with the
best the series has to offer Gamespot
gave us a list of the good and the bad
with the good being an incredible story
sharply written dialogue thrilling and
deep action Comet and a tremendous
soundtrack but the negatives they list
are dated design in some Quest structure
and some minor narrative shortcomings of
course can't wait to see what players
think of it when they get their hands on
it very soon